hey 42 here we humans have been going to
war for as long as we've existed and by
now we've gotten pretty good at it the
rules of engagement are fairly simple
one side starts a fight the other side
retaliates then the first side
retaliates to the retaliation and so on
and so forth until someone runs out of
land or bullets
or spears or whatever
take world war ii for example
on one side were the allies including
great britain the soviet union and the
united states
on the other side were the axis powers
including germany italy and japan
simple
or was it
because on the 5th of may 1945 just
three days before the fighting finally
came to an end in europe
one of the strangest battles of the
entire war took place
one in which america fought alongside
germany against well
germany
bizarre comical and deadly serious in
equal measure the battle for ita castle
was one of history's side shows to the
main event an episode mostly forgotten
when people tell stories about the
biggest war in history
but one that perfectly captures the
horror and absurdity of battle in one
neat little tail
like all good castles the one found in
the village of ita in austria was built
on a hill
constructed in the 13th century it was
originally a fortress serving as a base
for princes counts bishops you know the
type
before being badly damaged in 1526
during the german peasants war
the structure was eventually rebuilt in
the late 1880s but this time with a
distinctly non-military usage in mind it
first served as a home to a famous
pianist who knew there was so much cash
in tickling the ivories
before being converted into a hotel
around the turn of the 20th century
a few decades later it was rebranded
again
this time as an upper-class lock-up for
vip prisoners of war
in 1938 austria was officially declared
part of the third reich during what is
now known as the angelus
that made castle ita nazi property and
as the war developed the former hotel
became a sub-camp of the infamous dachau
concentration camp located about 120
kilometers away
being the rather fancy castle that it
was ita was turned into a special prison
that would house the so-called erin
haflinger or detainees of honor he were
basically prisoners of particular value
to the nazis for one reason or another
they included high-profile members of
german society that had fallen out of
the nazi party senior political figures
from enemy countries and even a few
international sports stars even though
very few of the evan haflinger actually
survived the war for the most part the
conditions they were kept in were
luxurious compared to the poor souls
living in the concentration camps
there were no prison uniforms and there
was no forced labor and they ate the
same food as the soldiers who watched
over them
some of these prisoners were even able
to live with their husbands or wives and
received rations equivalent to nine
times that of an ordinary german
[Music]
in the final days of the war which is
when our story begins
the 14 prisoners held at casalita were
mainly frenchmen his number included two
former prime ministers a couple of
generals a tennis champion and several
members of the french resistance
they were a pretty mixed bunch all
things considered
but they were unified by their unusual
predicament
you see by this point in the war it had
become clear that the nazis weren't
going to be winning
on the one hand that was pretty good
news
but in some ways it only made the
situation more dangerous for the
prisoners of ita castle the main camp at
dakao had recently been liberated by
american troops and the guards of ita
castle deserted not long afterwards that
meant our ragtag band of vip prisoners
were essentially free to leave but
doing so was incredibly risky the third
rank may have been collapsing in
spectacular fashion
but like an injured animal backed into a
corner the germans were becoming more
unpredictable with each passing day
the area around the castle was teeming
with ss forces with orders to kill any
prisoners they came across
and that meant that former inmates
now occupants of ita castle
were trapped
and it was only a matter of time before
the ss turned up
to try and finish them off
[Music]
with little of a choice the prisoners
prepared to defend themselves taking up
weapons that had been left behind by
their former jailers but it was clear
they were going to need backup if they
were to have any hope of surviving
a plan was hastily hatched and placed in
the hands of well
a handy man
zvonimir kuczewicz
a yugoslav resistance fighter who'd been
brought up to the castle to do some odd
jobs was sent out in search of
reinforcements
he made his way to innsbruck where he
located a division of u.s troops led by
major john kramers who ignoring orders
from his superiors immediately
dispatched a contingent of american
soldiers to ita castle but the group was
forced back due to heavy shelling and
never made it to the castle
when it became clear that help wasn't on
its way the prisoners at the castle sent
out a second man to go in search of help
czech chef and prison cook andreas
crobot
crobat made his way by bicycle to the
nearby town of virgo where he was able
to make contact with people claiming to
be part of the austrian resistance
i say claiming to be part of the
austrian resistance
because the first thing these men did
was deliver crobat directly into the
hands of major joseph gangle commander
of a unit of vermont soldiers
in other words one of hitler's henchmen
or should i say one of hitler's former
henchmen
you see gangl had defected taking 20 of
his former vermax soldiers with him to
join the austrian resistance these
ex-nazis had been busy defending the
people of virgo against their former
colleagues the ss who were arbitrarily
executing anyone they deemed to be an
enemy or a deserter which as it happened
was pretty much everyone
when gangl heard about the plight of the
prisoners trapped up at the castle he
immediately agreed to help with only 20
men gangl knew he couldn't hope to
defend it as prisoners from a full-on ss
assault so instead he used his
resistance connections to make contact
with a group of american soldiers he
knew was stationed in the nearby town of
kustin
there he met captain jack lee commander
of a tank battalion in the 12th armored
division who quickly agreed to join the
rescue mission
by the time the castle's new defenders
showed up for duty
they were a bit of a motley crew
captain lee's rescue party included just
14 men and a solitary tank
and gangl arrived with only 10 soldiers
having lost half of his men in a
skirmish with the ss along the way
we've all been given christmas or
birthday presents that spectacularly
failed to live up to our expectations
and
i can only assume castle ita's prisoners
were experiencing similar feelings of
gratitude mixed with grave
disappointment at the arrival of these
reinforcements
on the one hand it was great to have
some experienced soldiers to lead the
defense of the castle
on the other
24 men and a single tank
wasn't exactly an overwhelming force
and the direct assault on the castle
from a heavily armed ss division would
still be a huge problem which was a bit
unfortunate since that's exactly what
happened next
under the leadership of captain lee the
unlikely mismatch of both german and
american soldiers
lined up alongside castleto's political
prisoners in preparation for the
impending attack
they didn't have to wait long at dawn on
the 5th of may 1945
around 150 waffen-ss soldiers mounted a
vicious assault on ita castle
but although the ss significantly
outnumbered the defenders they hadn't
counted on meeting such a well-organized
and spirited resistance
the castle itself also offered the
defenders a huge tactical advantage
still the waffen-ss soldiers were a
fairly ruthless bunch and many of them
had had years of experience in the art
of war crucially they were also far
better arms than their enemy as the
fighting intensified the nazi soldiers
managed to blow up the defender's soul
tank with some well-placed artillery
fire they also successfully cut comms to
the castle
but not before major gangle managed to
place a call to the austrian resistance
in virgo requesting backup
it was to be gangle's final act of the
battle he was taken out soon after by an
enemy sniper while protecting former
french prime minister paul reinu
the battle raged on and soon enough the
german and u.s forces defending the
castle were running desperately low on
ammunition
but it was at this point that an
unlikely hero volunteered for active
duty
former tennis champion jean baratra
three-time winner of wimbledon and
apparently one brave son of a [ __ ]
dodging volleys of bullets and charging
the net of the ss soldiers the brave
volunteer somehow managed to escape the
castle siege on foot
and as luck would have it he soon
stumbled across the nearby u.s
142nd infantry
baratra quickly filled in the unit's
commanders on the grave situation up at
the castle before asking for a uniform
and joining the rescuers who immediately
left on a mission to reach hitter before
the defenders ran out of ammo
like gandalf at helm's deep the relief
force arrived just in time to break the
advancing ss forces about a hundred of
whom were taken captive
[Music]
from there it was all over pretty
quickly and within a matter of hours the
prisoners of ita castle were on their
way home
captain lee was honored with a
distinguished service cross for his
courageous efforts
and major gangl the only man to die
during the battle was celebrated as a
hero his sacrifice commemorated by a
monument and a street in virgo that
bears his name to this day
after returning to france some of the
liberated prisoners made a massive
impact on political policies that shaped
the country in its post-war years
so in some ways the battle for castle
ita was a history-defining moment but
even without those grand consequences
it was a peculiar story that's worth
remembering even if only for the courage
of the people who looked beyond national
flags and bound together to do what was
right
[Music]
thanks for watching